we have three main functions in
trigonometry three really important ones
which you will come across often they
are sine cosine and tangent here's a
fact the names of all the functions in
trigonometry sounds scary
if it's the first time you are studying
trigonometry there is a very slim chance
that you have heard any of these names
before we have learnt what functions are
a function take some input carries out a
particular operation on it and gives us
an output these three names are just
fancy names given to functions nothing
else let's assume this is a sine
function say it takes in a random value
theta it does some operation inside to
give us some value what value what
operation that depends entirely on the
triangle we know that trigonometry
generally deals with right triangles
like this one let's assume this angle is
Theta the side opposite to the right
angle is called the hypotenuse and the
other two sides are named with respect
to the position of this angle as this
side is right next to the angle it's
called the adjacent side this side is
called the opposite side as it lies
exactly opposite to our reference angle
please make sure you understand clearly
how the sides of the triangles are named
this is the triangle we will be
frequently referring to adjacent is the
side right next to the reference angle
and opposite is the side opposite the
reference angle now we are ready to
understand the sine function we will
look at the sine of our reference angle
the sine of angle theta is written as
sine theta observe that we do not write
the e sine theta will always equal the
opposite which is this side divided by
the hypotenuse each of these sides will
have a length so the sine
this angle gives us a numerical value
let's see an actual example we have this
right triangle let this angle be theta
and let the length of the sides be three
four and five units the formula for sine
theta is opposite by hypotenuse the
length of the side opposite the angle
theta is three units so we write a three
in the numerator the hypotenuse is 5
units so we write five in the
denominator the sine of theta in this
case is equal to 3 by 5 which equals
zero point six units that's how simple
trigonometry is all we need to know is
what the sides of the right triangle are
called